President Biden dealing with Fallout
from full gate after face planning hard
during the Air Force graduation the big
guy trying to laugh off his embarrassing
tumble while his White House says
there's no need to worry
he tripped over a sandbag on the stage
and briefly he tripped and got up and he
he got got right back up and continued
continued what he was there to do
he did not uh he there was no need for
the doctor to see him as it was related
to the fall and he's doing fine Biden's
Pals in the liberal media are covering
for him by accusing Republicans of
pouncing
Biden has this misunderestimated thing
right where people assume oh you know
he's too old he doesn't know what he's
doing and then he just keeps delivering
you know today he tripped over a you
know I guess there was like a sandbag on
and Twitter and the writer going crazy
it's the advanced team or whoever's
fault that they put a sandbag in front
of him I I trip in my own house is he so
enraging to the right because he is so
normal I'm a more than two years older
than president and I uh do just fine I
don't want to have a fall but if I do I
hope I get up as good as he did but
given voters concerns about the
president's age this is an image that
his critics are already capitalizing on
and pouncing on and while the majority
of Americans are concerned about a
second Biden term Jen saki sees the
bright sides of the president's problems
but she had to smear Republicans as
racist to do it
well if you look back joy to 2020 they
were trying to figure out how to take
them out they can't make him extreme
they can't really make him offensive I
mean one he's a white man who's older so
you know he is comfortable in their base
the many in their base
um but I think also they have uh
underestimated him at many times
well Bernie Sanders is old and white and
I feel very comfortable demonizing him
Sandra
uh because of his socialist policies I
hope Jesse this Biden fall I think
brings into question age and a greater
way for both parties and I think that's
an important point to make as we enter
the 2024 election I actually found a
local news article to where the
president was that day asking is this
fall a downfall for older politicians
for both parties so take into account
former president Donald Trump uh 77
years old he'll be 77 in June right 76
today 77 uh in a few days 78 come
election day Joe Biden 80. he'll be 82
come election day 86 if he uh when if he
finishes a second term in office I think
people don't want to see their parents
fall they don't want to see their
grandparents fall they certainly don't
want to see the president United States
they're president of the United States
fall
um the White House today could have
answered the question he went to the
doctor why didn't he go to the doctor
why wasn't he checked out she was asked
the question out of the gate the White
House today they're brushing it off as
expected but there's it's going to be a
bigger and bigger question for both
parties with age if people don't like
seeing this happen and they're going to
continue to elect older white leaders to
gensaki's point they're going to wonder
and they're going to be concerned about
somebody getting hurt if he's hurt and
taken out of the game we all know what
plan B is
Greg would you like to pounce on Biden
oh I'm so ready to pounce but get this
I'm not going to pounce on his physical
problems right because that's what they
want right this helps the Democrats to
focus on the body and not the brain he's
actually in good physical shape he's not
fat but his brain his brain's in big
trouble I would prefer a brain floating
in a vat of nutrients at this point if
it believed in science you know small
government and the right to personal
safety so he the horrible the horrifying
part about Joe Biden it has nothing to
do with falling but failing he is
failing America in a radical departure
for basically all of our American values
and that's either he's not interested in
crime he's not interested in education
he's not interested in protecting kids
from from activists and probably the
biggest assault that he's done in
America is on the Melting Pot I mean
that's a that's a prime American value
and he's turned the dial up on the
Melting Pot by by embracing oppress
oppression politics right he's now put a
Target on white saying that there's this
huge villain right extreme white Maga
extremists white supremacists but they
really can't find them but who knew that
the face of like an anti-American
Revolution would be Joe Biden's face and
it's because he's not there he's just a
husk he's being used he had he abdicated
his own soul for the job so I guess what
I'm saying is
yeah he's a frail old man and I'll make
fun of him to the day he leaves about
falling if that gets him out if that
gets him out great whatever it takes
whatever it takes but that's not the
problem that is not the falling is not
the problem this is a dark and dreary
path that we've selected in this man
that's the problem he has a mental
problem and a physical problem and all
the voters have said that two-thirds I
think I fell yesterday so that makes me
an expert
I actually pushed you yeah
there's no question the Washington Post
ABC poll last month made that clear that
two-thirds of Voters including of many
Democrats say that Joe Biden lacks the
mental sharpness and the Physical
Agility to be president and to many
voters agility is ability I agree with
Greg and been saying this for a very
long time let's not fall into the Trap
the art of politics is to tell people
not what they can see but what they
can't see when I think of Joe Biden I
don't think the guy falling although
it's odd I don't think I don't think of
the guy shaking hands at the air as
weird as that is I think of the guy who
with no rationale no plan ignore the
advice of all those generals and pulled
that up out of Afghanistan like that
leaving 7.2 billion dollars worth of our
intelligence and equipments for the
Taliban to have and what is the point in
this country of having the first female
vice president the first female vice
president of color if the women in
Afghan are less free have fewer rights
because her and her boss are so reckless
with foreign policy another point about
Joe Biden
um that is going to matter to voters and
I I'm not here to do the what about ISM
that it's Republicans do when Joe Biden
Falls I think of Joe Biden following us
as the rest of the country but the fear
of Donald Trump being president again
and the fear of Kamal Harris being
president soon makes many otherwise
reasonable rational Democrats say and do
crazy things they defend what we can all
see which is a president who's not up to
the job the founders in developing the
United States Constitution said that
president and the vice president must be
35 years of age and U.S citizens they
assumed that those two people would be
able to talk and walk properly when the
president Falls the first thing I think
of is Kamala Harris yes and our
Democrats does that cross their mind
every time you see them stumble like
that well every time something like that
happened one time and there was a
visible sandbag that the man tripped
over so whether that's the advanced
team's fault and he was up there for two
hours prior to that so maybe they didn't
think that he would be shifting back
that way whoever you want to blame
people trip and they get Greg tripping
yesterday can you no longer be president
is that there no of course not I just
saw it in Wilmington okay if you want to
let's take a a trip through history of
presidents falling let's start with
Ronald Reagan who's like the second
coming of Jesus
on the steps of Air Force yes and we had
I mentioned it yesterday we had a
president in a wheelchair who everybody
liked a lot who revolutionized you're
not making your point yes I am no you're
not because he's a Fed FDR was a
Democrat the only examples you're using
that we remember are Republicans you see
my point right and you didn't pay any
attention to it you did not care about
Ronald
even on television in the 80s
Jessica can I play some sound from
Donald Trump and you can react to what
he said about this I guess so but I have
other things to say okay so I'm gonna
add this Okay let's listen
you can't fall you just can't fall no
matter what just can't allow it to
happen then I better not allow
especially after saying this I'd better
not allow it to happen with me is the
FBI politicized is the doj weaponized
they're being protected and it's a
one-sided system it is a dual system of
of uh government there's a dual system
of you talk about Law and Order you
can't have Law and Order in a country
where you have such corruption
and Jessica you mentioned you wanted to
say something I did um so I'll respond
to that first but actually the clip that
I wish that you would play in is how he
started which was telling Sean that he
wanted him to stop going after the
president about his faculties and
falling and I thought that was really
smart as an old why are you grinning
like because I can't wait to respond but
you're not gonna have time because I'm
gonna go so long
you think he took the high road but no
he's a low row of pretending to be a
high road he thought that the Biden was
so pathetic you shouldn't make fun of
him that's
he might have had a moment of
recognition of the fact that his biggest
Challenger is 44 years old whatever you
think of DeSantis he's got a lot more
Runway coming than Donald Trump does and
that he needs to acknowledge the fact
that if he is running against Biden he
needs to look fitter than him he needs
to look you know more he does intact he
just saw it okay
all right anyway
to Greg's point about the president it's
not about the falling it's the failing
we had an incredible jobs report today
Sandra you were talking about it earlier
I don't don't speak for me on that
there's a real problem with real wages
in this country if people want to ignore
that that's your choice all right so
they had to rise the number up by a
couple hundred thousand jobs the
unemployment rate continues to be
incredible we have the lowest
unemployment rate for black Americans
and for Latino people got down to four
percent that that's happened got back
down do you remember
the Trump levels no it's lower than it
was at Trump levels the poster reflected
he's down on everything I don't care
what the polls say I'm talking about
reality and if reality catches up with
what's going on with the economy then he
will Biden will not be judged in the
same way as you know 90 on the wrong
track or whatever to be told how great
things are then no Sam to actually live
it they 83 of the country inspected
constantly with negativity about what
this President is doing and yes
Afghanistan was a mistake but I know a
lot of people who look at Joe Biden and
they think about the guy guy who's
standing shoulder to shoulder was
zielinski in the fight of Ukraine's life
to stand up to arrest the Democrats not
want him to have a second term
what like RFK no two-thirds of
democratic voters that's not to have a
second term it's 83 are going to support
him that's lower than the 90 that said
that they would have supported Obama in
the second term but it's that number
it's not right happy Friday Jessica ah
you're doing well you are yeah you're
doing better than most people it's gonna
be like I'm a baby like oh that's
exactly what Trump did with Biden you
know what just be you got to be nicer
too yeah Greg Greg was right Trump took
the high road for the first time ever
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else